c'est bientôt la grande finale de la
6ème édition du tremplin des voix donc
on reste dans la musique
les 18 candidats sélectionnés pourront
exprimer leurs talents vocaux ce
dimanche 31 janvier à 18 heures le
concours de chant habituellement
organisées dans les yvelines par
l'association est la voie en scène
propose un contenu 100% en ligne cette
année les organisateurs ont souhaité
rendre l'événement plus interactif
les spectateurs pourront donc commenter
et noter les participants en live
quand ils vont aller sur ce lien il va
voir ben sur leur téléphone portable et
l'ordinateur donc un espèce de deux
plateformes où ils vont pouvoir voter
pour les candidats c'est pas seulement
voter pour le candidat qu'on vient
soutenir c'est voter pour tous les
candidats donc c'est ludique
c'est le moment de découvrir des
nouveaux talents et en plus de
participer parce que c'est interactif
on peut envoyer des commentaires de
donner un peu son avis les lauréats
seront donc contacté dans la soirée pour
savourer en direct leur victoire parmi
les différentes récompenses un suivi
personnalisé par exemple sur l'année des
séances de coaching ou encore
l'enregistrement aux deux maquettes